gold bars what do you do with gold bars
put them in the safe it says Swiss Bank
Corporation I know but like
look man I know gold is valuable but
how are you going to move this amount of
money like what's your plan if you're a
regular person and you are like I would
like to hedge you know have a hedge or
or you know a hard asset or whatever
it's like okay I totally get it totally
get buying gold I have a little bit I
have most more silver than gold but no
it makes sense but if you're taking
bribes
what are you gonna do with it there was
a bunch of lots of envelopes different
envelopes that makes me think that
they're gonna traffic them they're going
to start trafficking cash off site they
may have already started trafficking
cash off site if they're in little
envelopes well I mean you know what's
kind of funny about this though is this
is a very old school New York New Jersey
political Scandal he has a bunch of Cash
Money gold bars Mafia very aesthetic
going there uh you know it kind of
amuses me to tell you the truth it's an
old school political history like
Breaking Bad right